- Here's a question.
If you could switch
places with one person,
you love your life.
There's nothing wrong with you.
You're great.
But if you could switch places
with one person who would it be?
- Oh my goodness.
I would...
I would switch places with
Elon Musk and I would do-
- Oh my god!
That's mine!
I am obsessed!
I've read like books on him.
I'm obsessed!
I think he's so cool.
That's mine.
- Me too!
- [Kelly] I think he's so interesting.
I want my brain to work like that.
- I want my brain to work like that
but I also want like
still part of my brain
that would spend money in an incredibly
like different, creative
way than perhaps amazing,
brilliant Elon Musk would spend it.
And I would still only
spend like, you know,
a billion in a day probably.
- Yeah, I know.
Isn't it just rough?
(Kelly chuckles)
No, I think it's amazing too.
All the things like innovative
weird kind of things,
you know, we'll come out with something
like kind of strange
and you're like, "What?"
But I think all those weird things,
they always lead to something amazing.
Like, you know, I'm so excited
about what they're doing
with space and, you know,
and how he talks about, you know
AI and like all that stuff.
I think it's so interesting.
It's so funny you picked him!
That would be who I'd pick.
- That is funny because
he's been on my mind and I did, well,
I actually haven't read a bunch of books
but I started reading a book about him
and it is fascinating.
And it's really funny that
you picked him as well.
See, now you've got to come on my show.
- Well, you know, I'll give
honest raw answers, ma'am.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Minnie] That's what I like.
- My mom is like, "You can
use a tiny bit of a filter,"
and I'm like, "Why?"